what
wow
uh-uh-uh
my goki
he
ah
I need to get comfy
what
Is this Freeman Ray?
Okay electric
that's right
That's it's good to me. Good morning. Good morning, good evening, good afternoon. I'm a tired baby.
I had a really weird dream that one of you guys offered me weed. I don't know why. It was really
weird. Like we were flirting with each other and then you offered me weed and I was like oh sorry
I've never smoked before uh I said something like I'm a good girl that hasn't partaken in
recreational drugs and my alarm went off and I was like okay that was rather weird so and now
we're here yeah it was a really weird weird confluent way to get here I'm not gonna lie
it's rather I'm still a bit frazzled it was rather um I was rather crazy I have to admit
the goodest girls refuses it well I don't know why my brain thought of it because I'm not
heard of anything in the news about it or anything like that so I don't know why my brain was like
I don't know there's a tiktok song that goes like past the weed past the liquor so I'm like
I'm wondering if that my brain would bloom all right then
I have cola today no tea I have cola I think uh I'm a I'm a wee bit sad okay because I think my
dad's a bit disappointed in uh oh well we all know what skin Icy would pick one of these ones
um I think my dad's a bit disappointed that I don't have a lot of energy after stream and I'm like
oh I'm feeling bad I don't want them to feel like I'm gonna be a shy guy I'm gonna be green
okay but yeah um how'd I get you guys in here again show room ID plus sign okay delta free Romeo
who are you squidding me right now for gore I had some weed last night so it was probably me
it's really good for eating ice cream yeah finally gives you appetite and stuff I never spoke about
that in my educational stream um thank you Joe Bono or shawnee's husband thank you for this super chat
are these wafflings oh my god it's fucking water wait oh you're con
ha I'm water wait first one fucking comment you can take a few days off to hang out with your dad
oh my god it's waterway how'd I talk to you it I'll say good luck as if I'm not gonna get
absolutely smoked I did not play this game they call it the munchie hello I don't know how big
the room can go I think it's eight people per track Jesse we need to race in Mario Kart Jesse please
uh what else can I see oh no that's picking a character sorry wrong one wrong one I'm excited
I'm always excited around the room um no it's not because I stream I think my dad doesn't realize how
like tired I am as a person so we went out and we had a we went to a Mexican place that was really
nice uh I got to pick up some candy for a hand cam stream you know the poppin cooking that Emmy did
with her rats oh the I just realized I remember he went delta three Romeo two mango and I bought
the poppin candy and then like I did I got some dinner food shopping type thing right and then I
came home and I was like I'm so sorry but I need to go to sleep now and like he kind of just looked
at me a bit funny and I'm like well I'm tired I streamed twice yesterday and I get really exhausted
easily and I just felt like a look at disappointment and I'm like oh but I don't have good needs like
that and I felt a bit like oh I didn't expect him to react like that and I'm like well I'm always
tired I'm exhausted I have so much to do and like wait hold on I need to kill a root model
I'm like I like I'm constantly working is this a lobby full one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten you can have ten per track
um is it ten per track are we full I think we're full oh it's 12 okay I'll hang fire I'll hang
fire sorry I'm getting apprehensive to moose down in my car oh yeah there you go there you go there
you go there you go um please the rest of you can have about how could you for the next education
stream define communism socialism just to the masses oh that's a bit this I may be at my pay grade I'm
not gonna lie I'm not that smart I'm actually I'm pretty close to being you know really not sure I
could start getting into that just remind him we be fling just means we be fling's got to keep
him busy we'll sneak in a bed to cover you in your sleep I literally like it was just the way he said
it like I could tell by the way he reacted he was like what do you mean you're going to sleep
because it was only three o'clock in the afternoon and I was like I'm tired I'm exhausted I need to
and I did I went to sleep for six hours I woke up and he was still awake so I had a chat with him
for an hour and then he went to sleep because it's like the usual sleep time and then I went back to
sleep and I woke up again and I was in the middle of a dream which means I could have slept much
longer you know I'm a special I'm a special low-energy beam at least one rest day a week
I'm pretty well said women are cute as well they're almost me
REM sleep moment right is it one two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
oh one two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve okay we have our enemies right
there's no teams normal items uh no cpu usage whatever that means races for race one race
who's got time for 48 races are you joking what kind of olympic freaking I don't even know the
controls I'm gonna be honest I do even know the controls 100cc no teams normal items no cpu usage
all vehicles for races uh
am I supposed to pick what would have I not played I cannot for the life of me remember
anything I remember the animal nap being cute big blue subway let's do a subway for that cat game
we please subway bell looks cute fuck waiting for everyone to vote oh we have to vote oh sorry
I thought this is this wasn't a democracy my apologies I think this is just a random lobby
yeah I put in a code it's friends and family best of 48 bro I would be hanging by a thread
I'd be last place but I'd be hanging by a thread right you'll need to let me come out this the
finishing line at a good time I know if you like go and then go of course it's been selected you
pick the London bridge I'm on you okay oh look at y'all from your oh god you're all you literally
look like my youtube stats I'm not even kidding I'll need to show you my youtube stats you were
all perfectly why am I first place I mean what ones the fucking drive button oh it's a it's a
whole day for driving wait I forgot no I wait why are we freaking Tokyo drifting why are we Tokyo
drifting reflect wait wait wait I'm not holding a oh come on fuck you bitch okay okay I'm nine
I'll take it as long as I don't come in dead last that's honestly a w I don't care what anyone says
everyone's Tokyo drifting I'm not wise enough to figure out why
wait what does this do what does the mushroom do how do you throw it I don't know oh that's
still like behind myself how do you oh hold on hold on oh okay how have you got so many things
around you how do I throw this oh it's a speed boost it was the other it was literally the other
trick whoa what I was pushing towards to the right side that was so weird give me my coin
back I'm actually coming in dead left I'm so sorry I'm so bad at this game I don't actually
comprehend it one bit so I played Mario Kart on the Nintendo DS and it was so straightforward
and then this is the next Mario Kart game up yeah damn right you're giving me a bullet
out my way you bams I need all the help I can get fuck you I'm not being last place I'm legit
not be no are you serious it's only us back here are you serious how are you ahead it literally
is only us back here fuck you I'm going infinity mode yeah yeah fuck you take that that's it take
it oh my god I'm gonna be 10 I can do it I can do it I can do it can I be nice please
I'm trying oh god is the track changing
okay okay maybe I won't be last after all just so you know you have auto driver system
which forces your path along certain paths it's a hindrance more than a help you want to turn
on oh is that why I went left instead of right because I was like excuse me oh my god I'm actually
gonna come in last I'm actually gonna come in last I'm actually coming in last I'm sorry
I'm sorry I suck so much I'm Tokyo drifting no are you serious what the heck
bro I'm not actually gonna come in last please I know I'm bad I'm like I literally do not play
Nintendo games like this a good result I did not finish why
am I seriously that bad Tokyo drifting in the last place don't ever type for the rest of this stream
send it when a woman gets behind the wheel stop why was that so but how do I turn that setting off
so I don't even think I think I'm gonna have to do it mid-game I don't even know how fucking
work this Nintendo I didn't play Nintendo okay be nice to me tiny tiny thank you for the hit
I don't even know how to turn it off that's the worst part I think I'll press I will press I can't
press the home button because that'll take me home surely how is it some of them are hidden
oh damn right they've literally said the 12th place person feels so bad we'll give we'll give her
the map like I've got one point to my name come on I've got one freaking point to my name this is
embarrassing no you need to put me at the start I need all the help I can get oh my god I can't
even freaking use the ions uh okay I got the boost okay MLG right I'm just gonna watch what the
reflins are doing are they drifting already okay don't drift don't drift the reflins aren't drifting
I'm just making shit up I don't know how it means oh my god merci don't look this will give you
emotion sickness if you're wanting it what is this oh please
how are you supposed to achieve anything in this game tight
okay I like that they respawn how are you guys going so fast yeah fuck you
uh no there'll be no ink in all math wait did a ghost just take my item but it didn't like
ink on me it's supposed to ink on me that's the whole point of the ghost ain't it oh come on wait
no no no see look the reflins are drifting here oh god I'm just gonna walk into the wall though
is it making you guys fat oh give me the bullet please I need any help please please
what does the gold mushroom do
oh oh I'm spamming it oh I'm spamming it oh oh oh hit him with it oh
the game's like please stop being glass we're literally giving you a bullet and a
fucking golden mushroom please stop being bad I can't help it okay this game this game is freaking
oh come on three reflins just went in front of me
and I got bit to the side I know I'm tense bro give me the the bullet right now give me the
golden king again and then give me the bullet you did that on purpose you did that on purpose
I literally saw you come up to me to do that oh yeah that's what I think you get my way yeah I'll
try getting my weebam yeah that's right yeah yeah yeah take that okay what does this do
yeah yeah I'm freaking creaming everywhere I don't know what on earth I'm doing oh my god I'm
actually gonna come in like a position I'm actually no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
there's two freaking bullets behind me no please I don't want to be last as long as I'm not last
as long as I'm not last please please stop this madness I'm not last I'm not last okay we win we win
we won we won we won we won I'm not last wow wow okay it doesn't matter that I only have three
points to my name I'm not last hold on I think I'm gonna have to move my character here
okay I'm not last that's all that matters I don't care what anyone says right we're visiting
cheeseland learning for course Aussie diva stop oh yeah it's paying it's paying that's what it is
it's paying it's paying it's paying we're having paying issues okay might as well be last we take
these reeflings why are you driving in front of mum you're supposed to drive behind literally
anyone's letting me win don't think I only remember your your wee gamer tags I know who you are I know
exactly what you're doing to me what's this what's this is that take a drink of cola it's going
making me burp funny now don't look at the fact that I have three points to my name and nothing
else okay don't look at the fact I have three points how am I last again I can't believe this game
rewards you for being good like I have for treating me honestly it's thick what thickest dread
thank you for the extended membership you may be last but you're top five in my heart uh aren't
you supposed to be like uh your number one in my heart and then I'm to go like oh my god thank you
so much what the fuck I'm top five who the fuck is before me who the fuck is this kind of back
compliment reeflings annihilate that man on site what the fuck I'm already losing a mario car and
now you're making me lose against like fucking top tier v-tubers I can't possibly compete with
come on just add insult to injury like go for it why not thank you for the extended membership
I appreciate it is you fucking what does that do oh it's fire yeah yeah yeah give me the give me
the coins I'm literally playing landlord simulator and Mario Kart on that bat stop bumping into me
I'm gonna call my insurance and tell them about how you rear ended me I have the dash cam footage
don't think I don't I'll let you lie to the police uh knowing full well that I have the dash cam
footage okay I'm sorry but actually I'm I'll let you lie and then you'll get done for uh what is it
what's the name when you pretend that you're in a crash but you're mine I've completely forgotten
the word when you're a when you're a naughty what happens if I beat him up oh he's an obstacle
okay well I just thought I could beat him up to be honest
oh Maui oh Maui right no one's touched me with ten foot balls then he touched
me on your regret it right both of us are doing the thing at the same time so it doesn't count
we cheating we cheated we're doing at the same time oh I'm fifth please I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
do it yeah right I need to go next to the chat I'm gonna next to chat in the next one because this
is freaking rough who's putting bombs on the road on up to it right now like when I said the high
table that doesn't mean infrastructure that everyday citizens need to use like honestly
some of yous are taking some of yous are really struggling with the instructions I've left you
for when I go okay yeah yeah yeah electrocute this faking injury for insurance fraud yeah
basically that so what happens if I have 10 points on my person I don't know
I saw in freaking fire told you're scaring me told you're scaring me he's literally oh I'm
finished eighth place I'm actually so good at this game sorry but I'm getting so much better
can I stand here I'm like trying not to be in the way of anything why did you ink on me
you inked on us don't lie I'm aware of your game more coins higher top speed is that how you guys
are going way faster than me even though we have the same freaking car are you serious
okay I've not tried that one why not that's how you're going faster when you turn you need coins
to go faster man all the car combinations are different okay that's even worse
they're using different cars what there's a faking metal in this bloody game as well for faking veins
I'm getting out I'm I'm gonna warn yous right now at the rate the stream's going I didn't
eight points I have eight points wait how does someone have less points in me is that even possible
and the nicest way is that even possible oh we're on a cruise ship together did I
guys tell you about they have adult cruise ships only and they do adult activities
on it and like they literally have rooms for it oh well sorry I'm a right side I'm a right side
and and like you can oh my god this is so cute sorry I'm just enjoying the ambience of the freaking
map sorry excuse me pardon me coming through I am legit I excuse you rude not them with the casino
floor not them with a gamble but yeah there's like adult cruise ships um oh maybe I'm probably
gonna be the one who stands on that banana because I am the one who takes the terrible
pathing I am the one the only one is rubbish at Mario Kart even though it's a kid's game
my enemies the reeflings they're rolling and smoking me I whip them up like not a canteen
I'm not whipping them up like a canteen oh I'm getting rolled by the game oh I'm the head
oh
okay I'm actually doing mlg pro so he's got freaking red why is the ship sliding where's
the stabilizers wait oh no green means just go forward okay I'm just gonna keep it on my
person do I not oh I have gold oh no go away I have gold you actually can't stop me sauce actually
I'm going mlg pro oh oh no how do you guys keep doing that sorry but how do you keep doing that I'm
like I'm actually getting rolled uh there's two freaking bullets behind me I'm getting I'm getting
nervous there they are right I'm safe again right can he touch me up Mars good luck good luck I'm
literally rainbow five you're not getting me you're not getting me I'm seventh place I'm not last
okay but I can't tell if the reeflings are starting to do you just knocked me out of getting an
item you're so stinky what is this
uh
they have hidden entire that's my banana I think maybe
oh my god oh my god oh my god not last not last not last I've got 11th I'll take it
that was the close one that was the close one we got we got oh we did it oh my god they have secret
pathways like I thought I was only on that one man god I want to be I want to be strong
these cards see thank you Bob or should I see girl lurking outside the ring cam POV
wait what do you mean nice try I did fantastic I'm so sorry I'm not even mad at myself for
doing absolute dug water that was so hard for no reason that you guys are so hard to play against
you're literally so much better than me in like all these freaking games okay please give other
reeflings a chance to join in when we put up the next map okay you can join if no one like comes in
but please give reeflings a chance like other beeflings a chance okay create a room
yes sorry it takes me right I'm not gonna be shite yet I'm gonna be oh that's that dog from
that one game oh it says inkling girl oh obviously I have to be the green one are you joking
right wait so there's like a metal with these standard car steel driver circus
circuit special oh wait I want to paint my ride I mean the sponge matches
okay the sponge matches this design sorry I'm going for looks I'm not actually going for
style points oh wait no I'm going for looks I'm not going for possibility press plus on the cart
press plus oh oh I'm covering up sorry I can't find a corner that's good for me to lurk in I think
I'm just gonna have to hide here maybe I just stand on you guys can I sit on you it's okay if I sit on
you right here reefling I sit on you right here yeah okay milk lick kiss suck dick that's the code
I'm sorry I'm sorry that's the code if you would like to come into the room I'm sorry I didn't mean
what I said I don't know why just rotate yourself and put yourself on top hi reefling
one two three four five six seven eight nine we've got nine stream sniping reeflings 99 stream
sniping reeflings I mean you made it in I I'm not just coming in this room honestly press Y
it's me and then press start speed acceleration oh there is a metal look at the top tier grip on
the sponge mobile I I'll just I mean I think I need speed I don't need to turn I just need
speed I am speed right speed whoa why are you so much speedier
okay and then wait you affect my speed what this is so silly okay I'm super speed
is that my 12 reefling 1 2 3 4 5 I can't count like that 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
okay we'll do the exact same thing as last time or should I force you guys to do a team so I have
a chance of winning surely if I come dead last but all the other reeflings come in first place
I can win surely that's how it works right
you got a disable the all steering oh
yeah gone now right let's
don't offer me the fucking dlc shit then what the fuck was that I ain't reading all that I ain't
reading all that the fuck let's let's become a truck driver dlc I'm not actually I'm not reading
all that put it in the base game motherfucker you maybe spend how much money on the base game and
you want more no dlc is the death of a game unless it's like actually although then again
the whole game's about racing so hold on a minute that's a lot of words too bad I ain't reading them
are we ready a little bit I put my head right here my head I like how the game lets me host
go first place even let's like yeah you need the help you can also disable it by pausing an
imprint l I don't know if my steering would be worse who who cannot connect someone can't connect
who's timing out who's got rubbish connection because I know it's no me oh
let's go oh I missed it up look at my little inkling oh I love her sorry I'm so cute I'm good
oh this is a cute map it kind of reminds me of that water map in kung fu chaos where you had to
walk along the um the oh sorry I didn't realize the pavements were that big sheesh wow hey who's
putting fire behind do you mean some of us are trying to leak I don't know enjoy driving
sheesh stop it who is putting green backwards why would you put something why would you put
a shell freaking backwards honestly honestly right let's get down to business let's get up did you
see that slingshot on that reef but I know it's only funny if you do it to the reef links not to me
don't slingshot that's red what is that I don't even know what that I am is am I even locked it
oh god we're ever breaking free we're so
so
come on let me win oh my god there's crabs on the road isn't crab emoji
a sign for cunning I don't know is that true did I just make up I'm sorry to I'm sorry to completely
derail from the wholesome nature of this game but am I going to take that take that take that
oh I've completely messed up my speak now well that was on me that was on me I was on me I have
my back okay well I wanted to go on the floor anyway I wanted to go and flip yeah yeah take that
get inked get inked everyone get inked wait why am I getting inked that was mine was it no
was it no that's right get tinnified oh you're so tiny giant too giantest time get fucked
get fucked you're all getting stood on you're all getting shoved in between I don't know something
I don't well I mean technically it depends where you want to take the giant oh was it last place
oh I wasn't last place let's go give me them two points I earned them two points
you are invisible oh it doesn't incone people I wish I could draw no money I'll probably be playing
different stream sniped games I think we're doing chess next week I'm not even kidding
I'm 1v1ing you in chess and I'm not going offline until I win who do I want to play what is big
blue big blue big blue good work incone us again I'll do it too your question to the crab is canny
not last place crab oh is that how you say crab in Japanese canny it sounds like canny like I canny
do that like oh so is that canny do that like I canny play mario car i'm shite
that's so cute so is canny do that me
not me with my two points sorry sorry to uh flex on you I know you're not supposed to flex on the
viewer but look I don't know what to like I just can't help but I'm just so good at the game
you cannot see the faces I'm pulling but I'm pulling some faces because I have terrible I am
oh look at the totes on the side of the road being all nice let's go oh I hope you guys always get
the boost honestly I thought it was one two and then do it okay okay okay okay okay it's fine
it's fine don't okay we've got a boot oh sorry sorry I did a drive how how do I bump you into a
pole and then you end up in front of me truly I am missing stuff I am missing it's severe IQ points
because this is get whoa there's a freaking uh the the intro the tourist things
san francisco things I don't know what they're called I've forgotten what they're called the
things in san francisco a tram oh a tram aye yeah then he asked glad then he asked about the tram
system in Scotland shambles I shan't who's putting bananas on the put your banana away right now
mister no I'm 11 no I'm not gonna make it I'm not gonna make it I don't think I'm gonna make it oh I
i can come whoa i got the green i got the golden
oh take this take this take this
i may actually come in a high position i'm trying i'm trying i'm trying i'm trying i'm trying
I'm trying. I'm trying. I can do it. I can do it. I can do it. I can do it.
Big jump.
I'm doing it. Oh my god, all of them just came in there. Did you see that? No!
You ruined it for me.
Oh, it's not the last lap. Hold on. Right. Sorry. Right. Bring the tension back. Bring the tension back.
But you did ruin it for me. I don't know who did that, but you actually ruined it for me.
Oh my god, you ruined my whole day. How dare you. Okay. Okay. Bring it back. Bring it back. Bring the tension.
Raise the tension. Raise the tension. Any tension. How you just literally took my little boost thing.
That could have been make or break. And what do you, how do I get repeat?
Up my arse. Honestly.
Honestly. This is strong. What are you, oh my god.
Okay, this is why I need to copy the reflins because you guys have actually played this game before.
What? We're literally sidewall drifting. Can I get the, the, the, the, no!
You took my eye arm!
Refling! Whoever did the lightning bolt, I'm actually sleep paralysis and I'm 12th place! No!
At Fanun Mama. Shame I can't join the race myself since I don't have Mario Kart.
I didn't. But I'm wholly content watching you tear up the track.
You've got this. Tear up the track? Are you kidding me? This is so bad.
Why did I pick this game for a street sniping purpose? This is so bad.
Right, let's do ace, ace outpost. Thank you, K-Dawn. K-Dawn, I'm saying it wrong.
After you mommy, shame you can't join because of the Mario Kart.
Don't buy it is my advice. It's fucking shite. It's so hard to play. It's not shite. It's just I'm shite.
But I'm wholly content watching you tear up the track. Why are you hyping me up over lie?
Why are you telling fibbers? You know, for a factory fling, I'm not tear it. The only thing I'm tearing
is your freaking back door trying to get to that bros day. I'm sucking it. It's so bad like.
Brov. How the a- Like, I'm not being funny. How is this not just like Mario Kart from DS?
Why is this something else? What do you mean they have to keep evolving games in order to
make them worthy of freaking selling? Like, Brov. I'm losing it. I think she needs the auto-steering.
I do too. I'm not being funny, but I actually do. Like, I'm forgetting to steer.
Okay. Right. I'm going to try hard, even though I've never played this freaking track before and
I have no idea what's up ahead. Okay. Okay. Right. I've got a speedboot. Who's picked this map?
Oh my god. Someone just went off the map. Oh no. That's a bit dangerous for me. I'm going to be
honest. I didn't know I had to turn. I didn't know I had to turn. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Have I gone somewhere? I shouldn't be. I mean, would they code it in? Okay. Okay. Okay. Him with
him with him. Hey. I'm trying hard. And I suck, even when I try hard. How is this possible? Be
honest. Have you guys all played this game? Is this like a super popular game? I know that sounds
so weird. Like, I'm sure it sounds weird to say it loud, but like, I just, I just, I fucking suck.
I suck so badly. Like, I don't, I don't remember ever sucking so badly in a game before.
Like normally like, oh, I get the hang of it. I comprehend what I'm supposed to do.
This is just annihilation.
Oh my god. That's funny. Sorry. That's actually funny.
You've cheered me up because you're letting me in your prostate. I love you here.
I might be the one getting annihilated, but no, it's time for you to bend over.
I'm literally not mad anymore because I'm getting prostate.
I suck. That is foul. Stop it. You shouldn't encourage me. Thank you, Kai, down to the super chat.
That is terrible. Right. Oh, I'm going to let all steer. I'm literally, how can you do that if I'm
spamming down the track? Sauce, but yous are cheating. Stop. I'm doing so well. And you keep
putting your banana on the track. How am I 12th place again? I was literally 8th place like a
moment ago. Oh my god. I don't even know if I'm going to make it. I need like a special, I literally
did not finish. I know that. Fucking all I'm getting is one freaking point. This isn't even possible.
When will you fricks learn? When you fricking fricks learn? Your ex is just complicated.
Skill issue. It literally is a skill issue. It needs to lock back in, bro. The only lock
I'm doing is putting one on your pee pee because I'm getting the disrespect I'm experiencing.
I'm just picking maps at random. I thought you were a gamer. Oh, that comment always comes up.
You're first to be R worded. That comment always comes up. I know you try to wind me up and it's
working. That comment always comes up. Oh, you've played games before. So you're not MLG in every
single game you ever play. You're first. Do you hear me? You are first. Oh, I hate this. I hate it.
Right, let's go. Yoshi Valley. Oh, fuck you. I'm done.
Right. This is impossible. I need, literally, I need to steer assist on because I'm so bad.
And then everyone's gonna hate. Maybe I'll have, right, go. Now that's when I put on.
Bro, so I put on a saying too late and then I'm too late and then I put on a saying too early
and I'm saying too early. Why is everyone going this way? Wait, what kind of track is this?
You can go multiple ways. Okay, hold on. Sorry, but the developer's kind of cool.
That actually doesn't seem like that bad of an idea. Like it seems really fun and different.
I'm kind of here for it. Hold on. Right, go. Oh no, everything's bendy though. I don't have
like a straight. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Come on. Let me try hard. Like for
one map, let me try. Why is there a random egg in the middle of the map? Stop flamethrowering.
That's it. No fire v-tubers. Fire v-tubers banned for Gen 2. I'm not having it.
What do you mean? Emmy technically can control fire. Yes, but that's because of the book. Okay,
it's all about the book. Wait, Emmy, be nice to her. Okay, she tries her best.
Right, fuck it. I'm going the right side. So I was, I'm going the right side. All right.
Okay, OOM said go underneath. What? This is actually really creative. Sorry, but they
actually did really well. Yeah, that's right. That's what you get with your green freaking thing.
It's my way, ya bobag, honestly. Wait, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Right, sorry, I can't. I need OOM to just kick in. Please, OOM. I can't
believe I need a freaking child's game to OOM me in the right direction. Get out. No way,
that just happened. Yeah, like, oh my God. Stop. There's ink and I'm getting tipped over. I literally
can't even drive. Did you just do that for, I swear that was targeted. I swear that was targeted
and that rifling legit was like, like, oh, there's mummy, I'm going for it. I swear that was, am I
going crazy? That was targeted. What was the name? I'm actually coming to your house right now and
getting your address. I'm writing it down. That is outrageous behaviour. I stream every single day.
I have so much fun. I do all these free audios and this is what I freaking get. This is what I get.
I fart in the wind. No, out my way right now. Out my way right now. No. Hey, it's dropping bombs!
I was fourth place. Oh, I'm tenth again. Whoever dropped that bomb, fucking, your mom's a hoe.
So as she actually was like, she can't even close them. Oh my God, I'm ninth place. I'll take it,
right? That was a good attempt. I'm ninth place. I got eight points. I got nine, I got four points
for that. So now I'm still second place. Oh yeah. After all that hard working effort, I'm still
second place. Yippee. You whipped wrong type of ink on my bed. Thank you, Kaidon. Anonymous. How
cute. Even mummy can have AC levels of brightness. When she's being a sore loser, head pass for trying.
Fucking the thing's like, yeah, nice try. You are second place. Please, you suck. Take your frustrations
out on me. Oh, it's already happening. Didn't you think I was snow? Right, we'll need to refresh the lobby
and pray that we have some empathetic refunds that'll let me go ahead. You know you're out there.
Are you squidding me right now?
Lord of storms. Angry Scottish caught fish noises all the bit. Am I actually getting that angry?
I don't remember. I don't really recall. Maybe I just like black it. Right,
right. We need someone. Can I make a green toad?
Why can't I make you green? Go green right now.
Why are you blue? Wait, you aren't as fast as the other one?
Watching you mold is the best thing ever. I'm actually, I don't know, that your next felt personal.
Oops, sorry. Sorry if I scared anyone. I promise I'm having a good time for the most part.
It's like, I'm enjoying myself. I get to play with you. Thank you, Jax and y'all, and thank
Anonymous says, I can't wait for all that Scottish rage to go off real, real, real. Right, Roy.
Right, Roy, surely you'll gain. Whoa, why are you so fast?
Oh my God, we're almost max speed. Wait, who's max speed combo? Someone must have it. Oh my gosh.
Right, ID. Kilo to
Foxtrot for November. The fats are fast. Oh, that's a little bit of a,
is that actually true? Is that the meta in the game that the bigger the person, the
bigger they are, like the faster they are? Are you sweating right now?
Gamer smack talk is when you know you're having fun. Just your mom's a whole. That's it. That's
all I've got going for me. Tydon, I'll offer up myself. If you win this race, I can't win anything.
I suck. Kilo to F alpha November. Oh, look at all my replays. Hi replays. One, two, three, four.
Is that Shaggy? That third one from the right? One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10, 11. There's one more. And there's Hatsune Miku. Hatsune Miku. I'm thinking Miku, Miku,
I'm thinking you. I'm coming in to take the 12th place. Are you going to switch?
Are you going to switch soon? You're actually, wait, is there 12? One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11. Okay, there's one person. I've seen what's coming.
Yeah, I've got the game. Oh my God. I didn't know you had the game. Right. Put in,
right. Sin sisters getting the last spot. Kilo to Foxtrot for November. I wonder now,
are we about to find out if Sin sisters as bad at this game as me or is she MLG pro? Hmm.
Heavier classes are faster than harder to move when rammed, but have slow acceleration.
Oh, I should go for acceleration and both shine. Oh, no. It's not going to go well for us. Is that
one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11. Is she correct? We'll see. They are
going to fight for that 12th place. Stop. I think we may actually be this entire next map is me
going to be going, send, send, leave me alone, send, send, go the right, go away.
This is a members only thing. Yeah. Anyone can join, but since coming in, you're not sin.
What the fuck are you? Who the fuck are you? That's not sin. Is that you and your, that can't
be your sin. That's not sin. There's no way. That's, is that your dad or something? What the
fuck? Is that your dad's me? Right. Well, wait for her to type, but if someone's, no, I'm no,
in your cheeky. Right. Is anyone, does anyone feel like sacrificing themselves so Sin can come
into this lobby? We flings and shows all we, but can I kindly request that?
Is anyone willing to sacrifice? There's, I need, I'll join next round. It's okay. Oh,
no, no, no, there, there, there, look, look, look, look, look. The reflins are popping off. Come on,
send, come on, come on, get in this fucking game. So at least I'm not last place. Surely you'll be
last place. If I was in there, thank you reflings. Right, let's see Sin come in. Do you look like
Is that you? Oh my God. Why are you so pretty? Is that you?
Sin's gonna whopper. Why is your freaking thing so pretty?
Okay. If that is you, she's greener. I'm not in. Oh, that's not you. All right. Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, wait, wait, is your freaking thing booted up yet?
I'm excited. Hold on. How'd that talk again? Let's wait for more players. What a shame.
I'm using tilt control. Oh, I'm already tilted. So you don't need to tell me.
I'll get you next time. Literally need to all the reflings unanimously.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, 11. Yeah, so Sin can get in. Sin's charging her switch.
I got asked because I only saw the end of the Ring Fit stream, but you're all good now. Yeah,
yeah, no, I passed out. And then that's how my body recovered. Next round, give Sin the code first.
What is going on?
And before you message me on, I'm in? Who are-
I'm in last? Wait, who are you?
One. That's you?
Are you the red? I don't know. I picked Bowser. Are you the freaking red guy in the suit?
On the right? Oh, did you just pick a random? Wait, press X and talk. Like, go like, goodnight.
That must be you. Sin for strong! Okay, that's so cute. Right, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, ten, 11, 12. Okay, we're ready. We're ready. Right, we know who to beat.
We know who to go for. We know who to go for. Let's see if me and the thing is,
I'll tell you the story when we play Elden Ring together, but you wouldn't believe it. But me and
Sin used to be very, very good gamers on a very specific game. Right, let's say the airport. Speaking
of modern warfare, Pop is on the airport terminal map.
Why am I Boris Johnson? I didn't even know I'm the one who switched. Honestly.
I don't know how VTubers play this game. This game is so hard for no reason.
Okay, who's getting the pick? Who's getting the pick?
Pinball map? It looks like pinball.
Monka. Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka.
Mumu Meadow is best map? Is that your opinion or is that fact right? Right, so my what? My acceleration
is do-do, but my speed is good? I think I've completely messed up this choice. Right, let's connect.
I got burned. What? No, you better not.
Wait, I thought you said my speed was, like, tall. Are you serious?
I thought you said my speed was good.
Bro, as if I'm not already debuffed enough. I thought you said my speed was good.
I am never picking a heavy again. Oh my god. I love yours, but I don't features any time,
but for driving in Mario Kart, this is terrible. Acceleration does not equal speed.
So then what with the fricking speed? Oh my god, there's random pinballs bumping in the map as well?
No, not now. Stop throwing your flamethrower at me. Go, baby. Right, okay, we're doing the AC
method. We're babying it the fuck up. Right, we're doing baby next round, and we're going to get
fricking, right, let's go, let's go, let's go. Oh my god, that's messing with my eyes, holy crap.
Yeah, I'm so big and clunky.
I mean, I'm not dead last, then again, send a disconnect. So I think there's only 11 people
in this map right now. Oh, this one's tricky.
I like how everyone makes a noise as well in game. Like,
like, I'm going to like all the way and do it saying all the way, all the way, all the way,
all the way, all the way. I love that all the way. So it's the best thing created in this game.
Oh, I love all these wee sounds. I wonder if I could do toad.
Oh my god, it's because I put flight mode on by accident. How do you,
how does one put on flight mode by accident? I don't even know how to access those panels.
Are you serious? I don't know how, oh my god, that slowed me down so much.
Oh my god, I've got like a little gear stick thing going on. Hi Wario.
That was on purpose. You had plenty of room for the both of us and you chose to do that, Wario.
Please don't think I'm not aware of. Right, fuck first place. Whoever, there's a blue shell coming
for whoever's in first place and it was Wario. Don't rub it in my face that you got the golden
freaking thing. Oh my gosh, Wario, you're so rude. Oh my god, this is so dangerous, this map.
As if you get that and I don't get that. Come on, who deserves it more, be honest.
Oh, that was rubbish. Somehow I held a button and it popped on. I'm going to great, right? Take
this as a warm up because you're all done, so Winston is in the lobby. Oh yeah.
Honestly. Wait, was that last place? Wait, did two reeflings just connect? I mean,
Sin obviously counts as a reefling. Excellent, excellent, excellent. Wait, let's do Sherbert land.
That looks quite easy. One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11.
Yeah, you were like, wait, why do you have a golden crown on you? Wait, did you win two in a row
and now you've got a golden crown to flaunt it? No way. No way, the game is rubbing it in her
face. Oh, Cryoniku's most points. Okay, we all spit on him. Got it. I know what to do.
Okay, I picked, I already forgot what I picked. Oh, there's the Roman Coliseum.
What is this? This course has been, I don't know what it is. What it is.
There's a missing person. I wonder who is supposed to be then.
Okay, second race. I am never picking a heavy again. Excite, bake. Excite, bake. Excitobico desu.
That was terrible. Are we like rally racers? Oh, we can jump off in the air.
Okay, I like that.
Yeah. Whoa. Oh, there's mud on the track. Oh, we need to be careful not to touch the mud.
Don't want my tires to get all sticky now, do I?
Okay, well, I just took myself for that. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Let me kick. Let me kick.
I'm eighth place. I'll take it. Oh, there's like, nah, you took my, wait. No. Oh my God.
Wait, how did you just drift over the mud? I'm sorry, but how did he just drift over the mud?
Is that for real? Like for real? For real? How did he do that? Did he cheat? Or am I going crazy?
Shake your controller when you do, when you jump to, sorry, I'm not even reading,
airplane. Shake your controller when you jump to do a trick and get a mini boost.
How did that refling go through the mud? But when I go through the mud,
it's like literally a bog. And it's, as if it's not like a two foot puzzle.
A two foot puzzle. What the fuck? A two foot puzzle.
When you go off a ramp, wait, shake my controller.
Oh, wait, how does it know I'm doing that? Oh my God, I'm starting on that. How does it know
I'm doing that? That's so cool. Oh, that's so cool. Oh my God, it knows when I shake.
Feel the noise. Okay, that didn't work. Oh my God, it knows when I'm shaking.
Shake and bake. Oh, oh, it didn't do it that time. That's okay. I forgive it. Shake, shake, shake,
shake, shake, shake, shake. Oh, I'm jerking off this controller right now. Oh, that's so fun.
Thank you for telling me. I didn't even know you could do that. Oh my God, I ignored the mud.
It is chaos. It is chaos back here. It's absolutely chaos.
Right, I got eighth or something. I don't know. Oh my God. Shake your controller or press Z.
There's no Z. There's no Z. Is it triggers? Be honest. There's a bumper in triggers. You'll have
to tell me in Xbox terms. Wish I was Johnny's controller right now. Improvement, eighth place.
All I had to do was start doing... Let's do tick tock clock because I have tick tock brain rot.
The triggers are ZR. Why on earth would they call them that?
I don't think I could have been hit by any more Ioms.
Honestly, me every time I go around the map, I'm getting ruled.
All you had to do was literally... Lutuber figures out how to win Mario Kart. All she has to do is like
fucking... I just spilled cola down myself if you heard me get a napkin. Sorry.
Give me coconut mole or give me death. I'll pick coconut mole. Where was it? What are my points?
Oh my God, I have seven and I'm still last.
This game is far too difficult. I said what I said.
Okay, third race. We've got one more and then in comes... I'll have... I don't even have freaking
discord open. Right. You guys will let us in and so I don't need to... Oh. Oh, how beautiful.
Oh my God, it reminds me of Christmas. Oh wait, can I do tricks in the air? No, I can't. Okay, sorry.
Sorry if you hear me like violently shaking in the background. It's because I'm trying to get it working.
Please stop bumping into me. Oh, he almost went off the road. I think he may have went off... Oh, it's spin.
Whoa, what? How am I not dead? Take that. See, if I use that against someone, it's funny,
but if someone uses it against me, I'm not laughing anymore. Okay, this is like really going for my
eyes. I have to admit this is a lot of color scheme going on. It's a chomp chomp not to be confused
with womp womp. Any chompers? Oh my God, I'm actually... Sorry, I'm actually not doing that bad. Hold on.
If I can get lucky and not have items used against me, that'd be grand.
I might actually have a decent position unless the reeflings are... Okay, they're plotting. I'm
back to sixth place. I'm getting put in my... Sorry, I'm getting put back in my spot again. Sorry,
I got a bit over... I got a bit overconfident. I thought maybe there was hope. Uh, I spoke far too
soon. I had hope. Okay, I had hope. Stop! That's what you get for being a doodoo haze. Oh no, I missed it.
Jump jump jump! It's starting on them. What does that even mean?
Who was I fourth and I'm ninth? Are you serious? Oh, I'm still dead luck. Oh, well at least I'm
locked on with another reefling. Get wrecked. Both of us suck. What are you gonna do about it?
Are you gonna kiss me? Team Slug is getting off target. Start, stop! She's kind of getting
the hang of it, not really. Is this where we find out mommy is more sensitive? Jumping,
not quite, but showing on your butt. Oh yeah. Right, one more map. I want to pick Hyrule because
we saved it the other week. Link, you came to town. You came to save the princess Zelda.
I didn't 100% the game. No, about 100% at the figurines, which I've never done before. That was
actually pretty crazy. That was crazy. Okay, last lap. Ready. Oh, we got coconut. This doesn't
look like coconut mole. Is this like coconut mole version like 3.0 because of how many times
they've got it? You just got coconut mold. Wait, is that a thing? Is this a Mario meme I don't know
about? Stormy, I will become a chomp chomp. Wait. I'm not even mad that I suck. This is actually
a really good song and map. Okay, I don't really want to go in the fountains. I don't think that's
going to speed me up at all. Oh my goodness. I just realized there's a mini map to the right
that I can see what's kind of up ahead. This is not like Nintendo DS coconut mole. I don't remember
any of this. Who is doing burnouts in the middle of the track? Who is doing burnouts in the middle
of the freaking track? That's outrageous. Get on my ticket right now. This is? Oh my god, I don't
remember it at all. I'm trying. I'm trying so hard right now. Is it going to peel? We'll find
out in a minute. We'll find out in a minute. Sorry, sorry replaying that was me. No, I'm sorry.
I said the S word. Yeah, I'll take that. I'll show you. No, I said I'm sorry. You're supposed to...
Wait, he's got boomerang in his hand. Is that for me? Right, okay. I was getting worried that boomerang
was for me. I had to put on the brakes a little there. If you go to the fountain and jump, you can
do this trick again. Why is it putting me up the wrong one? There is the other thing.
What a few... Okay, trick. Again, I got another bullet. Oh my god, I have a chance to actually be
in a decent rank. Not the only time I have a chance to win is when I get given the bullet.
Okay, please cars, please, please, please, please. My best score yet. A fifth place. Oh my god,
not the only time I literally have a chance to get any score is when I'm five. And that puts me
third place. My best ranking. My best ranking third place. Oh my god. Oh my god, record breaking
on Team Slag. I got third place. Last third last. Sorry, not third place. Third last. Third last.
I did it. And it probably would have been less if Sen was playing because she would have beaten me.
I'm not gonna lie. Not gonna lie. Sen would have beaten me. The only way that worked is because
I got given a bullet on ninth place. Right, I will reset the lobby and we'll make sure Sen gets in.
That was fun. You're ready. Yes. Right, let's do a baby. Oh my god. You know, she looks so determined.
I actually ain't seen. Fifth place. The deal is a deal. Time to offer myself up. Reflings. I'm going
on the head. No, wait, what? I thought I had to win. You had to win. Right, so what do I want?
Acceleration? Acceleration. And then we need a bit of speed or not, I guess.
Okay, max acceleration, but that takes in so much speed. I've got no idea. I'm just going for it.
Sorry, I have no idea what I'm doing. Look, I'm here for a good time. I don't know anything.
Don't be surprised if we don't stream Snape on this game again in the future. That's all I'm saying.
She's doing an acceleration build. Oh, that's the MLG. Okay, the lobby code is...
I'm stretching, sorry. I need to stretch first before I can even think. Right,
a Jai, a T, a 4, a P, and a 2. I have no idea. No, you won fifth or third place.
No, you won fifth or third place, lol. I'm offering my body to you.
Reefling? I don't know how to tell you this. When I said I was third place, I meant I was third last,
which is an improvement on being second and last last. I'm so sorry.
Thank you, Kai no one for this purchase. When I said third place, I meant third last because
I don't have a chance. Are you strawdier? Are you in? Is she the one with the pink hair?
L plus ratio, let's go. Is that? I'll give it my best shot. Is that her? Go easy on me.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven. Okay, we have room for two more
if that's Sen over there in the pink. I don't know if that's Sen or not. Go easy on me.
They're crying. It says I'm currently spectating. Check in my head, the lobby isn't full. Why would
you say that? I'm looking ass in the game. How dare you? Show yourself. Literally, the lobby's not
full. It says one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven. Wait, Sen, have you
bought like the online pass from Nintendo servers? Surely you have them. Yeah, they want you to buy
like, it's like Xbox Game Pass but for Switch. Do you have the online servers?
Yes, okay, you do have it unfortunately.
She was in the lobby last time. Oh yeah, you were. What a dumb ass.
Wait, it says there's a missing spot so I don't know how you're spectating.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven. Yeah, there's room for one more.
Restart and hide the code with your body and then send it to Sen. Oh no, the refillings are
polite enough that they'll back out. I'm seeing twelve. Wait, can I not count? One, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven. Where's the twelve? One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven. No, you're trolling me. You're making me double think numbers
and stuff. Did she press flight mode again? We will never know. How are you spectating?
Now I'm going to go out on a limb and say that's not Sen. Okay, now there's twelve.
Wait, so why are you spectating and not in the lobby?
That's bizarre. Why would it make you spectate? I'm not making you spectate.
If there's any reflings that have had a shot to play with me today, is it okay if I kindly request
you lead to try and get Sen in? Thank you, reflings. Oh, there she is. There she is. Boris Johnson.
Thanks for showing up, Boris. We missed you. We missed you, Boris. Then you come. Okay, I don't
know why that didn't work at first, but that's definitely her. There's Boris. Hooray. I'm using
tilt controls. Wait, are you guys like rubbing it in my face that I have to use evens? Wait,
why am I in but I can't see that I'm in? Wait, your switch doesn't even display it? I don't
want you to time out again. Are you guys like rubbish connection? It says I'm currently... Well,
you're in my lobby. I'm not sure about that. I'm using tilt controls as a... Oh, we missed you, Boris.
Why is it so hard to try and team up with the freaking VTuber? I don't know why. Like,
anytime two people try and collide that are VTubers, the thing just doesn't work. I think it's
on your end, Sen. Yeah. Oh, no, this can't be. Can't a moment. Well, just go for it. VTuber scoff.
Literally, like, Minazur were like talking and voice chat for like two hours before the collab,
and then like 15 minutes before, everyone needs to clear the lobby and let me be far.
Do you want to try that? I need to... Right, okay, hold on. I'm going to reset the lobby.
If everyone could kindly let Sen come in first, okay?
I trust you guys to show the code, but you're not all going to come flying in, okay?
I have no idea what I selected. Right, the code, Sen. Would you kindly...
Sen, the code is 042 Charlie Gamma. Sen, getting special treatment.
Favouritism by my VTuber? More likely than you think.
Shocking behaviour. Shocking. Okay, let's see if she can come in.
Anyone else who comes in is getting nuked off the stratosphere.
Well, you didn't hesitate, did you? Right, can you see that, Sen? Because we can see you and
Big Boris Johnson. Ah, you guys didn't he? Oh, she talked. She talked in game.
She talked in game.
One, two, three, four. Ew, what is that?
You look like a... Oh, okay, five. One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, twelve. Oh my god, we did it. We did it. It only took us like five whole minutes.
Smile. Why is my name Boris now? It was Sinfors Johnny and now I'm Boris?
Stop, that's funny. No themes, normal items. Sands from Undertale? How is that Sands from Undertale?
Who have we not played? We've not played Grumble Volcano, as far as I'm aware.
It was meant to be a part. We're doing it. We're playing together.
One race only. Wait, did I mess up? Was it not four races? I've been leaving it on default.
Did I mess up? It took us so long to come together and I'm going to ruin it.
Hi, thanks for joining. You're welcome to stream snipe. This course has been selected.
In chat, your character said four races. Damn straight it is. Okay, here we go.
Okay, okay, we're doing it. We're doing it. We're ready, baby Rosalina. Come on, baby Rosalina. I
believe in you. Are you squidding me right now? Zion! It's a miracle I could still watch you at 720p
out here in the boonies. I believe in you, strongy. Are you putting your face in the wrong
streamer? You should put your stonks in as Sin. I'm not even kidding. Right, where is she? We need to
try and enable Sin. Either we'll enable Sin or we'll just go for it. Thank you for the tips,
Zion. Okay, I don't know where she is. I can't see her. Is she behind me?
No, Sin are officially boosting me. Stop, could you imagine? Right, I'm going to keep the green on
me so if anyone touches me they get walloped. I said what I said. Right, we're going up the stairs.
I'm literally copying the reeflings. I'm keeping the green on me.
I'm getting inked on. I'm getting inked on. But it's not that time. I don't know. Give me like
less than a week. It's less than a week. Let's do this. As much as I like holding on to that.
I like the maps that change. Like they have changing elements. Like the trainers in the way
and stuff. I like that. Oops. Oh, the game all steered me away from that. You're so stinky,
Mr. Video Game. I don't know. I think Sin might be behind me. I have no idea what character she is.
Oopsie. Oh, well that worked.
Where is she? Is she ahead? Oh my god. And before she's like first place right now.
And she's like I've never played this game before. And she's just absolutely annihilating me.
Oh, there's a car. Oh no, I'm in the gravel. Get off the gravel. Off the gravel. Off the gravel.
We're almost there. Whoa, whoa, whoa. You can destroy the subway car if you have
the dee dee dee dee dee dee dee dee dee dee dee dee dee on. Come on. Come on. I can make it.
I can make it. No, I can't make it if you guys are doing maneuvers like that. Don't be so red.
Where is she? Oh god. Damn, she just won't be when I train on one. Literally, the person is so far
behind. Is she actually? So you're telling me the secret to winning against the Reeflands
is to call in my friends that I've never played Mario Kart. Billets should be banned.
You should be getting them. You should be getting the billets because you're last. The game should
have a higher rate of getting the billets. That's hilarious. Wait, are you on your desktop?
Can I get you in a Discord call? If you're at your desktop, I can literally open up Discord right
now and get your voice on stream. I don't know if you're on your desktop though or if you're just
chilling. How does that help you beat the Reeflings? Well, it'll make me higher up in general.
Baby Park? Is that the worst map in the game? Baby Park?
Yeah, that's unfortunately how it is when you're left.
So you need to use the triggers to like tilt and then a boost you or something, but I don't really
understand it. So yeah, I just kind of ignore the whole mechanic. I'm sure the mechanic is
literally the reason why I'm losing, but oh no, I'm on the sand. Don't go on the sand.
Don't go on the sand. How is there sand and snow?
Oh, it's clouds. We're in the clouds. Oh, it's Jack and the Beanstalk. That's so cute.
Okay, I like this map. Wait, I like this map. It's very cute.
You go around a circle seven times? Not in this map. I only did it. I did everything like four
rounds of three, four rounds of three. That's not even a sentence. Do you want to try again?
There's four races in a circuit. Come on, oh wait. Honestly, I'm like, should I just
shove myself into walls? That may work. You know, I read his pen bananas on the track.
Literally, you know how like, there's always a music tag and they're like, oh, on the beat.
His pen bananas on the track is going to be my one. Okay. Oh no. I've just checked the HUD on the
right side. Sin person. She's like on her own all the way back there. I feel really bad.
Should I drive next to her? You know what? I'll wait up. I'll wait up. Oh,
she's got a bullet. She's got a bullet. She's coming. Okay, she's coming. There she goes.
Look at Sin. Right, let's spectate her gameplay. Let's, ow, let's spectate that gameplay.
Okay, she's cat. She's going around. She's picked up an item. Oh, she's picked up a bullet,
bro. If I can, you keep up. Not me last place because I was trying to freaking hang out with Sin.
Bro, she got a bullet. Why am I sideways? Okay, that's fine. I'll love it. Okay.
I got kicked. Why am I hacked by a random boy? Wait, how did you get kicked? You were literally
right in front of me. Wait, you were. I came in before you. Why? How do you get timed out?
Oh, Shrani got her hair putts and she can't hear us. Goose trying to go. 78% on town, mom.
I'm going to do Wailed Woods. This is where I'm going to live with the Weeflings.
How do you keep getting kicked? You have like other rubbish connection or something.
Shrani, love. We feel a love. I just caught that in the last tip.
Band items are for with these. Sin just can't win. You might be able to rejoin me.
I'm not sure. Are you squiddin' me right now? Piney, spiny.
Tell Sin that so far she has earned more points as Boris in this Mario Kart Tournament
than he did in his last popularity poll. Bruh. I ain't seein' that. Bruh.
Thank you for the tip, tiny spiny. Bruh. Bruh. Two. No.
Oh, finally. I did it. Where the hell are we? We're in France! You know how you can tell?
Because that's that one monument. They want to shut down the traffic at it because it's so bad.
Oh, wait. Isn't the Olympics on? Or isn't the Olympics about to be on in France?
I don't know how to say it in any other language. V gets Lou Olympics.
Lou Olympics are awful.
Okay, everyone's getting bananas. To say a banana- Oh, who just bummed me? To say banana in French?
Or say unne-banane? That's right. Bananas are feminine in French. Why? I don't know.
No. Wait, are they? Did I just make that up? Be honest. I think I just made that up. In banana.
It just means one banana. A banana. New banana? La banana? What the heck am I supposed to do with
all these? I have no idea. That was so much for no- I don't know what I'm supposed to do with those.
They are feminine- Why would a banana be feminine in any language? Be honest right now. We all know
what a banana is. I'm not sure. It makes no sense. I literally make no sense.
And it's like, I'm pretty sure Bos and French are feminine as well, but a man's winky in French is-
Are you kidding me? You took my thing. You took my golden thing. You're so stinky.
I'm actually so stinky. Whoever did the thunderbolt? One, you aren't Zeus. You aren't him. And two,
you stink. I can smell you and how hard you're sweating to ruin my game. That's right.
You're not pheromone maxing. You're pheromone
bogan. Oh, that's right. Take that insult. Take that insult. Take it. What are you going to do? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Where am I going? Oh, thank God. Oh, thank God. Oh, him just came in right now because
I did not do that. That was- Oh, it says unironically. Okay, I got it. Oh, this is what I need. So I don't
have to aim. Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go. Okay, I made
it 8th. I literally cheated and made it to 8th place because of that.
Die Banane in German is female. Spanish is word un banana. She hates us all, girl. He can't recover
from that emotional damage. Yeah, please don't be surprised if I don't play this game on stream
tonight for no particular reason at all. It's because I'm a share of the game. Yeah, for no reason,
I don't really think we're going to be- Royal Raceway, King Candy, D.K. Donkey Kong, D.K.
Donkey Kong is here. I'm finally back to kick something. The banana in Turkey is a must.
I don't know why she's breaking out, but that was fun that she joined in anyway.
She's probably got prepared for streamers. I don't know if she's streaming the day.
She does Elden Ring and she actually plays it properly if you want to watch her Elden Ring streams.
If you want to actually watch someone play Elden Ring,
send sister on Twitch at 8pm GMT. I actually don't know what time she's streaming.
I can't remember what time she's streaming that. It's a bit later. I think it's a bit later.
Are you- Luigi, you just bumped me like three times. You know that cost money after the second
throw to the second bump. Oh my god, we're bouncing though.
Received it. No, no, don't start guessing my freaking name. That's naughty replaying.
That's naughty and you know it's naughty. Oh my god, I think I just sniked Rosalina. I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry. More like Pozalina, who's all she cares about. I'm just- I don't know what I'm even talking.
I saw that. Whoever's in that freaking red car, I literally saw you just try and green me.
What's your name? Mar? More like Shitebag McGee. Don't ever do that again. I literally saw you
attempt that in Four Cave. I was shocking. I was shocking, honestly. Streams every day.
You know, I'm actually speechless at that attempt on my life that you just made.
Oh, I can do a flip. No, I can't. I'm too late. I'm actually speaking- Oh! Who just pinged that
Oh my god, he went halfway across the map. Okay, last lap.
Okay, I can do it. I can do it. Yatta, yatta, yatta, yatta. I'm doing all the gambas,
but nothing's working out. Okay, nothing's working. I'm just here for a good time, not for a long time.
Okay, please. Please understand. Okay, yeah, fuck you. I'm so sorry to that reflin. I'm so sorry.
No, I'm so sorry. It's not me. It's not me. It's the game. It's the game.
The game. Oh, I almost messed up so badly. I'm third place. I'm third place.
I'm sprouted. Oh, I can't believe it. Oh, I got 11 points. Oh my god. I'm still second place though. Oh.
Oh. Oh, I'm still second place though. Oh no. Oh no. I thought I did so well there.
I'm sorry. I got so excited. I thought I did it.
No, literally say, wait, was that last place? I'm not last though. I'm not last. That was fun.
Yatta, good game. Okay, we do one more. Maybe two more. We have time for two more. One more two more.
Wow. You're not last though. Broke him third place for nothing. Stop. I'm trying. Right.
Why are we like male? Shirley peaches the Barbie to use. Wait, hold on. I need to do the plus thing.
Right. You want me to go all out on acceleration? Okay, the burger mobile is acceleration. The wheels
are acceleration. Why? Will on airs does any of this mean? Right. Let's just fucking go all out
on acceleration in the burger mobile. Okay. I swear. I don't know why your switch is missing.
Congrats on 15k, by the way. I have so much ASMR debt. I'm actually 15,000. That's insane. Hold on a
minute. I ain't laughing. Hold on a minute. Am I actually 15,000? What? I am. I'm 15,000. What the
heck? Reflins, where are you all coming from? What the heck? So one, that is some more video
kind of blew up. The real thigh cupping and the please let me hold it like blew up twice.
Yeah, I looked up and there was a fix. So let's find it. Congrats. Make it 20k before the bathroom.
Well, the 15k ASMR celebration stream is a thigh cam ASMR. Like you're literally going to see my thighs
and it's going to be pointed down on the ASMR making. We do thigh ASMR
and like you can see me like do the the making. So I don't know what to do for 20k in all honesty.
I ain't thought that far ahead. I've not even got my freaking ASMR collapse up and all that stuff.
I'm going to aim back. What? Why are you gifting me 50 memberships for sucking at this video game?
El Jeff. Thank you. What the heck? Thank you. El Jeff. That's amazing. Oh my gosh. That's so
what? Why are you giving me gifted memberships for sucking so badly at a game? That's huge.
Thank you. I think I've just unlocked a new emotes slot for that as well. What the heck?
Thank you. Congrats to those who caught it with your face and enjoy the emotes. We have more emotes
on the way and by more emotes on the way, I mean I need to ask you guys what more emotes you'd like
to be on the way. Thank you so much. For those of you who don't talk in like the actual chat,
I think there might be a prompt to say to accept gifted memberships. I'm not sure,
but you might see it now. I don't know how it works. But yes, anyone's welcome to join the lobby
because I think Sin can't get in at all. But thank you so much. El Jeff. More like El Chad.
Waps down 50 gifted memberships. Walks away doesn't say anything. Chad behavior. Shocking Chad behavior.
I'm a little nervous. I'm a little nervous. Gulp. I'm you. Hooray.
Isn't that a deal? How do I join in? There's a room ID code to the right of my head.
I'm pointing to it with my tongue. And then you use that code to join. As long as you have the game
and stuff though. If you don't have the game, unfortunately, I can't help you pass that.
El Jeff doesn't look at explosions. He just walks away like a badass.
Reefling Delilah. How many is that? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12. That's us. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12. Let's go. Oh wait. No. You guys are being forced to carry me. Do you understand
Reeflings are in this lobby? Okay. Wait, you got in? Okay. You're being forced to carry me.
You're being forced to carry me. Do you understand? This is online so I can't join.
Strowny moment. I literally do not know how to play. Well, you're still carrying me anyway.
I'm going to vote Sherbert Land. Oh wait. Melody Motorway? Oh my god. Melody. That hit
VTuber Melody. Project Melody. Strowny carry at the end. Team Strowny versus Team Sin. I got the
game. I just need to know how to hop in. There's like four of them. I should be like multiplayer
and then a code. Oh yes. Because I'm last. I'm kicked out of Team Slag. I see you. Wait. It didn't
let me pick. I just picked two teams. Am I going crazy? Don't forget to hit that like and subscribe
button. Oh, I'm such a real VTuber honestly. Do you enjoy playing games with me, Reeflings?
Don't forget to like the stream to let me know you want more stream sniping. I say that as if
we're not playing chess next week. Literally brush up on your chess. Okay. The red team versus the blue
team. Let's see what happens. Sauce to my team in advance, bro. Sauce to my team in advance.
That's right. Let's see. Go.
Okay. Now this is curious. This is very curious indeed. Because now that it's teamed,
I am actually sorry. I'm going to try hard for this one. I don't want to let my team down.
I don't want to let my team down, mom. I have to try my hardest in Mario Kart. I really don't want
to upset anybody. I can't let them down. They try so hard for me. Literally every enemy ever.
No, mom. You can't forbid me from doing the tournament. I need to try everything in my power.
That sounds like every enemy protagonist. Please. I tried my best. Fuck it. I just destroyed a train.
No, I can't give in yet. I have to try my hardest. My team, they're relying on me.
Oh, I need to do everything in my power. Maybe stop with the bombs. Oh, but I can't let the bombs
stop me. Even if I'm not first place, I have to give it my all. Come on, team. Wish the best for me.
Oh, shit. The short cut for a minute. Sorry. I'm too busy. It is an enemy European right now.
Oh, no. I've been struck by lightning, but I can't let that get me down. Oh, my gosh.
I'm almost there. I'm trying so hard. But in the end, maybe it didn't even matter for my team.
I'm on the last lap. Oh, no. A bomb stopped me in my track.
Okay. Oh, wait. Just help me. I'm going to squid everywhere. Come on, me. Come on.
So is anyone to let them down on Ironically? I need to try hard right now.
Donkey Kong, you might have ruined this map for me, but that's not going to stop me.
Oh, my gosh. I'm blasting ahead of the enemies. I can do it. I'm almost there. Please. No. Please.
I'm actually trying hard and so much. Don't be rid. Don't be rid. I'm trying hard and so much.
I don't even know what color team I am. I'm about to come. I'm about to buzz. Okay. Hold on. I'm
just going to let all of you take over. I'm trying my best, please. Believe in me, team. I might not
be the first place, but I tried my best. Come on, buddy. Team mate. Come on, buddy.
Strony. Strony was a fanboy. Is that what you're saying? Your father, the villain,
and he sent all your enemies. Wait, what was the result? I didn't pay attention. Did we win?
I actually did worse than Strony and I'm on our team. No, you're supposed to carry me. Carry me.
And then we'll play this game again if you carry me.
Anyway, I'm in now. Hydration check.
Okay, I seem to have the inability to not be able to drink properly. I have spilled cola on me three
times a stream. I don't know what you're doing to me, reflings, but I'm getting nervous. I'm getting
shaky, okay? I've spilled cola three times on myself. I don't know what's going on.
Your comments made me laugh so hard I messed up. What are you talking about? I'm just a regular
anime protagonist. I just have to try my best for my team, even if I don't come first. As long as
I try my best, everything will work out in the end, right? Thanks, math, for the 20 gifted memberships.
Congrats to those who caught it with your face. That's right. Even if you're not the protagonist,
you can try your best to be the main person in your story. It's okay if you're an NPC.
I'm so sorry. This is so first. Okay, let me try hard. I don't want to let my teammates down. Hold
on. Unironically, I don't want to let them down. Even when I try my best, I'm such a baka. They're
going to know that I'm not good at this game. Maybe they'll figure out that I actually haven't
played it in a whole year, and the only experience I have with Mario Kart is actually in my childhood.
Oh no, I can't let them know. I'll just pretend I'll fake it until I make it.
This is absolutely tearing up my voice. Okay, okay, we cleared that banana off the tracks.
That's my DJ signature. Banana off the tracks. Bananas and pajamas. They're coming in the stairs.
Bananas. Oh, red. Right, I must be team blue. There's no way I'm not team blue.
Due to the data that I have collected, i.e. on the right side, bottom right of the screen is blue,
I assume that is me. Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, let's focus up. God, this track is tiny.
Every is so tiny. Okay, hold on. I need you to kick in, please.
Right, get flamethrowered. There's nothing you can do about it.
Oh, did I do it? Did we win? Your team blue. Okay, where's the ASMR? I think you just
liked someone on your team. Oh, is that even possible? Thank you so much again,
Math for the gifted membership and LGF. That's insane. I'm pretty sure you guys have just
collectively unlocked an emoteslot. Oh no, we're losing. I just, oops, I think we're losing.
Ah, I'll do the electro dome. I don't know what. Oh, we're losing. Red is carrying.
Who hit me with the shell? We're on the same damn team. Press L on the card screen or something.
So close to the 96-69. Team Sen is pulling ahead. I can't believe it.
Reflames, you're supposed to like, I don't know, carry me.
And before you guys are like, you're uncariable. How do I pause? There's no pause.
You would have to do it mid-game, I think. I don't know, maybe you could do it like right now.
No one is allowed to say I'm uncariable. Okay, only my butt. You're allowed to insult my butt
and say my butt's uncariable. So sit on your face. As it, if you don't carry me, everyone's
getting a 30-second face sit. I don't care if you can't breathe, it's over for you.
Oh, we're playing the Legend of Zelda map. Okay, let's go. Hyrule. Third race. Two remaining.
Well, one remaining technically after this.
Uh, two, wow. It's always really that much of a negative. I feel like it helps me.
Oh my god, the coins are runes in this. Oh, I love it. Or rupees, sorry.
Oh, I love it. I'm like way behind again. I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying.
Wow. Oh no, I never shook it in time. Oh my god, the soundtrack is Legend of Zelda as well.
This is so cute. I can hear it. I can hear it. Oh my god, that was a Hyruleian sword. Oh my god.
I love this one, sorry. Oh my god. References that I actually know for once when it comes to
Nintendo. Thank you, Minish Cap. We love you. We love you, Minish Cap.
Please owe him, so I don't have to freaking steer.
Thank you, Zarya. Anything for you, Refling. Anytime, it's a pleasure. I think my next ASMR
upload is me sitting on the make. I don't think I'm going to get in trouble for it,
because it's literally me just... Oh wait, no, I'm out of breath on it.
I don't think I can do it.
Oh, the wee baby's laughing. She's like,
honestly, I'd be laughing too. Okay. Wait, let me focus up. Let me focus up.
I'm just fucking throwing everything.
Oh my god, it's so long-inspired. I love Legend of Long.
Any Legend of Long fans? Sorry. I'm trying to make the best of the situation, but I'm so bad at the
game. As if you just streamstepped my box. I hope you're at least on my team.
Oh my god, someone's going to head with a freaking bullet.
But not to be confused with the hit band, Bullet for My Valentine,
which I can't even remember one single song from them.
Oh, that's like so fast.
Oh, I love... I'm sorry. Best map, sorry. I'm biased right now. I'm actually biased.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no. I'm so tiny. There's nothing wrong with being tiny, okay.
SPH Bulls, rise up. Seriously. Wait, go, go, go. Okay, I got seventh place.
Is that what that means? Did I get seventh place? Oh, I did actually get seventh place.
Oh my god, that's actually not... Oh my god, I'm like legit seventh place. Hold on a minute.
Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. Oh, can we bring it back though? Kiki9 is trying
as hard as to carry all of us. Sit on top, lad. Seventh place, you got one position higher.
I'll be so positioned high on you. I tried, I tried. I can't do it off the top of my head.
I tried so... No, no, stop showing me the DLC, honestly. Get away. Hold on. Let's pick.
Did we end up? Have we played the cheese? Let's do animal crossing.
Send best team, send red top on top. Thank you again, Zarian, for the tip. I will suffocate you.
Can blue make the comeback, unless all of us collectively like five head this?
I don't think so. There's only so much carrying the top blue person can do.
I'm always last, but Team Sin winnin'. Bravo, literally.
Like, oh my god, I can't believe it.
Send it on top of strongy. If anything, I'd be dominating Sin. Thank you, I'll be here all week.
Okay, final race. This is it. This is it. Let's make or break.
Let's go. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute, Luigi. We're on the same team now. You just can't
win. You just can't win, Luigi. Why am I drifting that way? Please don't do that again.
Wow.
Oh my god, that's actually so creative. That's so good. Thank you, Sleepy Phoenix.
That's so creative. I'm sorry, I'm bumping everyone. Call me Mario because I'm going to carry.
What? Call me Mario because I'm going to princess carry that peach. Hey, smooth with it.
I'm so slow. I can't believe there's unironically a Mario meta. This is insane.
This game's too difficult for brainless like me. Sometimes we just want to
be dumb. Is that too much to ask for? To be left alone in my dumbassery?
Oh, there's a ch- What?
What?
Literally, what were we supposed to do? A freaking train? Wait, that was my teammate. I'm sorry.
I didn't realize you had to be tactical with items. I thought they all did it. Like, oh, that's my teammate.
Oh my god, I'm 11th now. Oh, there was a train. I wasn't looking. This is why you shouldn't
drive whilst on your phone because you will not see what you have to do unironically.
Oh my gosh. Last lap. We're on like a whole different map.
Stop. You're being bully. Okay. Hold on. Oh no, no, no, no, no. You're not supposed to do that.
I'm 7th again. I mean, it's something. I'll take it. Can I get something that'll speed me up? No,
not really what I want to do. I'm just going to have to- Oh, I just walked into my own green
shell. No one saw that. That's embarrassing. I actually just went into my own green shell.
Bruh, I suck so bad at it. I'm 10.
I think sin won. I think sin won.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, we lost, but that's okay.
Yatta. Go Red Team. You did it. No way. We don't even get a participation trophy. You guys get like
a nice shiny trophy. And what did we get? Nothing. We don't even get a little medallion.
Like, oh, congrats. You did it. Bruh. So rude. Oh no, now we have to get sound. Exactly. This is
your punishment for not carrying me. That is shong. GG. Do you want one more or will we call it
there and redirect into someone? It's up to you guys. Do you want one more or 16 points?
Blue caught up from 30 points. That's huge though. You get a moist handshake and you will love it.
One more? One more? Okay, like, I'll restart the lobby just to give
other reflings a chance to streamstamp, okay? And then we'll do one more team game,
and then I might be able to win. I might be able to win if reflings carry me.
Don't be surprised if you slip on my banana. That is actually really good.
Does that have my soundboard up? No, I don't have my soundboard up. Dram.
Drat. I don't have my soundboard up. Okay, I just, I'll just pick we...
Eepee. Okay, we're called Daisy now. Daisy, Duke, Spiky. Wait, is that not Madame?
No, I've not played Daisy. Okay, sorry, sorry. I'm being dumb. Give me a second.
Right, what do I want to do? Speed. Maybe let's do a bit more speed.
Well, that wasn't exactly what I wanted to do, but hey, oh, well I did it anyway.
One Sierra. Eight Sierra. Zero. I got kicked again from the final race, but your team's still one?
Bruv. Just say you're lucky, Sin. You weren't even participating in the last race and still win.
I dare you. These accusations are shopping.
Hey.
Ah, hold on.
Is Sin in? Are you one back in? The game just hates me. Do you want back in, Sin, or are you just back in?
That's right, I'm forcing you to watch my stream. What are you going to do about it, Sin?
Only if you streamed on YouTube, I could redirect into you. Oh my god, I let a reflin last one. Oh
my god, Sin is so selfless. Like, look how nice that she is. Right, one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12. We're all here. Right, carry me. Do you understand? Do you
understand me, reflings? Oh my, I realize I'm dumb. I'm too embarrassed to confess. Wait,
have you been disconnecting yourself manually? I'm not going to switch the teams. I'm just going
to leave them as is. So, I'll let the teams randomize. Sin, have you been doing something?
What have you been doing? Did we play the Animal Crossing? I don't think I did.
Yeah, last game. So, you guys better not let me lose.
Call everyone who is in my team. I am summoning you to possess yourself with the most gaming
spirit you could possibly have. Gaming kitsune. Strony, I need you to stop my face more than
I need to breathe. So, please, smother me. Repeat. I'm going to end up killing you guys by accident.
So, basically, so, basically, I realized I was in the full game. I looked back on my phone at the
screen and was further back in the stream. So, I thought we had another game, but it was just,
I wasn't watching you live. Was that English? Good luck. What? What are you talking about?
No. She was behind on stream. So, you thought it was, right. So, I was behind on stream. Right.
Okay. On the last race. Right. And what, and you ditched? Right. I'm on the red team now.
Okay. Oops. I'm on the sand, but that kind of works.
Okay. Come on, red team. Do it. I'll beat the blue ones up back here. Don't worry. I'll handle these
reeflings. They're all getting smothered one by one. It's so ugly. No, not sin being gone.
Now I'm last place all over again, bro.
Diabolical. Diabolical. What are these wheels as well?
Oh my god. I'm trying so hard. You have no idea.
Oh, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I think you're a teammate. I just sandbagged myself.
Why is it when I do so good? I like completely mess it up. Whoa. You almost touched me, Luigi.
That felt personal. That felt personal. I'm not the one. That felt personal.
Mm-hmm. I'm aware. I'm aware of what you've done. I like that noise.
Okay. Okay. I'm not last. I'm not last. I'm not letting my team down. Hold on.
Okay. I'm gonna, yeah, fuck you for one. You're next if you touch me. Do you understand?
Take, yes, if you understand how fucked you are. Shit. Right. No one touch me. No one touch me.
You're gonna regret it. Yeah, fuck you. You're done. Yeah, but you're done for.
That's right. That's right. That's right. That's right. Tell them how it is. Tell them how it is.
Tell them how it is. Tell them how it is. Yep. Yep. Tell them how it is. Wait, how did you?
Okay. I actually am not letting my team down. I'm actually not letting my team down.
Nine points? I'll take it. Right. I was in the fourth on the last race, so excuse me. Get on my
level. Oh, right. Okay. So the game didn't have a fit. Oh, right. Okay. Oh, my God. They need to start
giving me bullets right before the finish in line, like, all the time, because it's actually
meaning I'm not last. What have we not played? Have we played Wario's Stadium?
Well, we'll find out in a minute. Fourth place? That's crazy. Stroni has learned how to cart
the Mario in one stream. Any Mario of carters? Any cart to Mario's? Right. She literally did
just get on my level. Why, everyone keep bumping into, who driving these carts? Honestly.
Shocking behavior.
Question for those that say mommy is carried by the bullet and not our team. How heavy is
mommy's cheek? I have no idea. I've not weighed myself in months. I have no idea what my weight is.
Want to find out? Want to find out, huh? You want to find out in person, Franklin?
Don't think I won't do it. When other streamers shyly, I push further and further
to the inappropriate level. Oh, no, I messed up the start, right? Bruh, I'm too busy,
six and to fucking focus on the game. Hold on. Okay, okay, focus up, focus up. Come on.
I would do the, I would do the anime voice again, but I'm not gonna lie. That really hurt my throat.
Not the mud, not the mud, but someone please think of the mud.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch. The ring of fire and it.
Keep going, teammates. I believe in you. Go on without me. I'll be fine.
I am messing up so badly. Don't tell the red team. I am absolutely
just decimating any semblance of success for them. Don't tell them though. They don't need to know.
They don't need to know, okay? They don't need to know. It's fine. They don't need to know.
Oh my god, right, okay. I'm safe for a little bit in case anyone wants to use anything against me.
Oh my god, we did a flip though. Oh, we did a flip though.
Okay, I'm still a living place, so it's not looking that good. I'm gonna be honest.
It could look better. It could look a lot better right now. Okay, let's not, okay.
Oh, look, I was fourth place last time. It's fine. I was fourth place last time.
It truly is fine. Hold on. Let me grab these and then Priya get a bullet.
Give me two bullets in a row if you love me. Thank you. Thank you. The game loves me.
I love you too, game. Right, ruin. I'm literally coming for you. I am literally going in front
of your ruin. You are literally my opposition. What is this? I don't want to attack my teammates.
Oh, fuck it.
Well, it worked. I'm ninth place now. Look, it was tactical sabotage. It was tactical sabotage,
okay? It was tactical. It was tactical. There was a point. Speaking of sabotage,
by the Beastie Boys. No way he got in front of me.
No, I messed that up so badly. I think I could have done a lot better.
Come on. Oh, my God, it sounded like one of those chickens that you're squeaking and out.
You know those chickens that dogs play with? Those like plastic things? Do you know what I mean?
Are we winning? Oh, we're winning. The rubber chickens. Yeah, literally. Should I do rubber
chicken ASMR? I don't know. I've just discovered I can kind of make that noise. I went strolling
to make the noises too. It's so accurate. You're going to lift me. Have we done sweet canyon? You
don't need the rubber chicken. You are the rubber chicken. Girlfriend, rubber chicken ASMR should
sleep. I've just discovered I can kind of make that noise. Oh, my God. Hydration check.
We're doing it. This is how she distracts the other team. Yes, close your ears, my teammates.
I'm going to distract them. Are you going to be a good boy for me? Are you going to let me go
in front? Don't you not want to see the view from behind, little wreathling? Don't you want to see
it all? If you're in front of me, how can you see me? Come on, wreathling, for me. Just for me.
Let mommy be first. Did I work? Did I work? Come on, red team. Filter in, please. Oh,
no, I messed up. What is this map? There's a lot of bumping. I see a lot of bumping. Not going
to lie. I'm getting bumped to smithereens right now. Maybe that should be my tactic all along.
Maybe I should just do that. Oh, this is so cool. I like this map. Are we going back in the war?
Are we going out of the war? I'm sideways. What's a piranha do? Wait, what? I've never had a piranha
before. How strange. How strange. That was an interesting item, a piranha. They must be super
rare. Okay, okay. Back to being 12th place. Hold on. I need the bullet, please. Give me a bullet for
my Valentine's at the Mario Kart battle pass. I just shit on my ass and I bootied up my PC
because I need mood to get that Fortnite battle pass. Again, I messed. What am I doing so wrong?
I tried so hard, but in the end, it probably isn't going to matter, but I'm trying. I'm 9th
place. I'll take it. I'm 9th place. This is the best I've done and however long. Right, okay,
it's fine. I just don't want to be last. Oh my god, there's a bullet. Stop it. You're such
bullies, reflinges. You're supposed to let me win. What do you mean my voice isn't safe? Say what
I'm fucking angry. Reflings, let me win. Fuck take. Let me win. Let me win. Let me win. Sorry,
but let me win. It's actually, it's literally by a ball here. Right, I'm passing. I passed the blue,
so I'm winning. Stop putting bananas on the track. The bananas go in marshmallow. I'm not on the track.
Oh my god. I actually want to win so badly. No, I don't want to hurt my teammate.
I'm literally 12th place. Bro, I'm literally an anchor. I'm literally an anchor. I'm getting
did not finish. I'm that. Oh, I'm an anchor. Are we winning? Oh my god, I'm such an anchor.
What is it? Oh my god, we're still somehow doing it. I don't know, but we're still somehow doing it.
Oh my god, clutched three. I did not clutch. I was third and got hit by a hundred items,
so now I'm 7th. You literally kept me from starting that right. Oh my god, I'm getting annihilated.
I've been Mario circuit. Oh, shaggle falls. That's cute.
The red carry is crazy. Literally the only way I'm going to win this game
is by one, sorting into teams, and then two, getting carried by those team members.
A fun idea. Make it a challenge. Whoever are the third, three people that finish behind
Strony are considered first, second, and third. No, it's not going to work like that. There's no way.
KK9's back must be hurting a lot by now. We are winning, at least I'm faster than a fish woman.
How dare you? I'm literally so good at swimming. I'm not being funny. You put me in a water game
with you right now. Is there a multiplayer shark game where one team is like the sharks and the
others are the divers? I'm going to need to look into it. Maybe we can play that as a streamstank
game. I'm a really good swimmer. I want to take up swimming again, actually. Okay, well, I messed
up already. It's fine. I didn't want to be first place anyway. No, no, I'm not taking it personally.
Oh, you can fall off the map in this road. Okay, I'm going to be a Sunday driver
because I didn't... Are we on a space station? You know, the maps are getting a bit extreme,
map that I've met. A bit extreme for my liking, you know. Oh, we did a little stun pose. Yeah,
this map is crazy. Yeah, fuck you. I'm going for a knee. Sorry, your team blue. Get right team
blue. No, no, no. Yes. No, not the red though. Not the red though. So much for auto turning.
The game said, no, you're not getting it. Okay, that was so lucky that little bump pad thing was
there or I was a goner. I'm not going to lie. My steering is terrible. I got saved by bumping into
that. What is he holding? I'm so scared to go past him. Okay, can I even... I can? Oh, right. Oh,
right. Hold on a minute. Oh my god, both me and Roon are actually trashed. Sorry, Roon, to pick on
you, but literally both me and you are doing the exact same mistake. Right, hold on. All right, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay. Okay, okay, okay. Let's do it. Let's do it. Let's do it. Let's do it.
Oh my god, right. As long as I'm in front of Roon and sauce, but you're actually my competitor.
No, no, he got a bullet. He got a bullet. Why did I not get a bullet? Oh my god, this map is so hard
for no reason. I'm stuck. Okay, right. No, it's fine. I didn't want to be... I don't want to rank
anyway. I didn't even want to finish this map. Of course I want to do not finish. Did not finish,
bro. Bro, please give me another bullet. I need all the help I can get. Are you serious?
No, I can't use this one on this map. Breastrokes with Strony.
Sorry, this map. I'm so sorry, teammates. I hope you're carrying. This map is impossible. I can't
do it. I honestly can't do it. My freaking baby mobile is just... Bro, it's no happening.
Yeah, I need two bullets, please.
I've got one, and then I'm going to lightening everyone. Sorry if I just got you, but you're
getting annihilated. Wait, I've got another bullet. Maybe I can become 11. Maybe I can do 11th
place. That's right, bro. Suck it. Suck it, bro. Take it. Take it like a giveaway fun. I'm not
Did we win? Oh my god, it's so close. Did we win?
Did we win?
Did we win? Is there one more?
Oh my god, we won! We won! Yay! Thank you, teammates. Thank you, KK9Grey, Dreal, Yoshi, Feathers,
Diablo. We did it! We actually won!
This game, I was getting more mushrooms than the Navali or Maros.
Are you okay, Brian? Oh my god, Brian. Are you okay? He really struggled. Oh my god, the only time
I win is by cheating. Thank you, Reeflings. Thank you, Anonymous. Wait, I'm going to get Brian to
replay that because I don't know why he said it like that. He was really not feeling it.
Are you squiddling right now? Are you trying again, Brian? This damn game, I was getting more
mushrooms than the Navali or Maros. The Navali or Maros? Thank you, Brian. Thank you, Anonymous,
for the tip. True, real 4K. I'm really literally greeting right now. I'll literally beat you up.
I'm so sorry. I got the least amount of points, but at least Momay is happy. Yeah, I'll get you
next time. Wait, how did you do that animation? How did I do that? I'll get you next time.
I'll get you next time. That's so unfair. I'll get you next time. I'll get you next time. I'll
like that. Never happier to be being also the game you ask is the one called Truck Versus Divers
and the game is called Depps. Oh, we might look into that. Velo Marios. Honestly, my first
time playing, I don't care if I win or lose. That was so good. That was literally so good.
I'm so happy with that ending. Literally, I lose the entire time, but right at the end,
refling, clutch it up for me feels good, Mom. Don't mean to fudge you. Don't mean to fudge you.
Right, where's my customization? Who's streaming? Is Emmy? Oh, AC's live still? Okay, we're going
to redirect into AC. I never get this opportunity. Okay, we're redirecting into AC. Get ready for a
party because she's doing karaoke. Thank you again so much, Reflings, for hanging out with me. You
get one big wet water kiss, okay? You like that, didn't you? I did my best. Good refling. Okay,
I see you, Giffy Gibbers, tomorrow for crying stream. Apparently, we're just crying tomorrow,
so yay, we have fun at that. Okay, bye-bye, Reflings, kiss, kiss,
enjoy ACiCle. We never get to read into ACiCle. AC time, AC time.